Họng thống với điên xương lai Nikolas Maduro nghe hamichin hôm nay đo đang tải thông đẹp đồng tiên trên mặt sà hội.
Kể tu khi bị bắt chúng chỉ dịch quân sự gió Mỹ tiến hành hồi đồng năm,
trong trên bầu ông cho biết bản thân và phù nhân Silvia Floral S vẫn khỏe mạnh kinh định và bình tính.
Đồng thời kêu gọi nghe dân phía điên xương lai B duy trí đang kết và thuốc đầy đối thoại khu rai.
Ông Maduro nhấn mạnh đập con trạm của Hasa, thả thử và trường xong Hoa Bình cho sang đây là con đường cình thiết, đều định tình hình trứng ngất.
Hôm biểu này đưa ra trường bối cạnh với điên xương lai đang trải qua biến đồng chính trị lớn,
sau khi lãnh đạo đình nhận biến bắt sử, theo con 1 tị cũng tế ông Maduro và phù nhận hiện là bị 3 giữ tại Mỹ
và đã ra hồ toal yên bàn bởi kết thảo bộ liên qua đến 1 bán thả tuy ý và tội phạm xương cú xe.
Sao hành người đều bán bỏ có cá bộ ngành.
Bề phía quá xinh tình chỉ quyền mi trời sang, chính dịch bắt giữ là một phần trong mẫu lục tự thi pháp lợt và bảo đảm anh anh.
Chúc kì đó, phía bên trong rời bà mùa xúc xe đã chỉ trị trị lộn thấy này, trước rằng nơi làm đẩn vì phản trường cú xe.